[Musique]
il arrive tout on avance 6 et 7
musiciens à l'heure pour le coucher de
soleil sur chambord avec un message pour
le public chauffé à blanc
deux ans d'attentes et autant de report
la soirée à toute libération
à 70 ans l'anglais n'en finit pas de
faire rêver
c'était magnifique ah ben tu étais super
parce que c'est pas la première fois
qu'on le voit mais c'était magique avec
le château derrière pas que du bonheur
on est mécontent on est homo bien on va
rentrer et elles sont encore une fois le
cadre fait que c'est magique épilogue à
à soixante dix ans et toujours sur scène
quelques heures avant les portes ouvrent
sur une foule qui n'a pas le temps pour
être au plus proche de la scène le
chanteur lui découvre les lieux en début
d'après-midi pour les derniers
ajustements avec patrick roberts un ami
et violoniste australien invité pour
l'occasion sur la chanson fera giles
[Musique]
autre violon à se produire quelques
heures avant le duo grande jouant pour
l'occasion à lui main devant les vingt
mille personnes présentes sélectionnés
parmi des dizaines de groupes locaux et
validé par style lui-même il raconte une
expérience
presque comme les
finalement le concernant lui même on l'a
vécu comme n'importe quel autre concert
parce qu'on fait notre truc et on est
devant des gens et si l'on dise oui ce
sont vingt mille on fait quand même
notre truc par contre c'était surtout
l'appréhension qui a été très différente
et le fait d'y penser pendant
les producteurs pensent déjà à demain et
à une autre tête d'affiche prêt à faire
vibrer dépôt de chambord
[Musique]
m